I'm very happy that you could be here
today Jared because today is in fact
your birthday you guys you guys have a
tradition on your birthday of
celebrating in a certain way yeah want
to tell us what that is here we are we
streak that's not that's no that's not
really what we do yeah that's yeah
technically is usually the next day
because our birthday we've had too much
to drink you drank you get together and
you drink when we were when the show
first started we used to we used to
sneak kegs into each other's trailers
yeah true story Warner Brothers don't
listen yeah and and we were done as we
were done filming as the years got got
got on then the the kegs became half
kegs and then they became the little you
know the little five litre Heineken kegs
oh yeah yeah and then it just became
embarrassing it was maybe a beer and now
I don't think it's any it's like we do
this weekend
well Jared I want to tell you that it's
as nice Jensen has arranged a special
surprise for you in honor of your
birthday if you bring those out here so
we do that right now oh there we go we
have a
the best yeah now see you see how he
tested that out yeah
because traditionally it's a keg stand
yeah if you're only in a fraternity is
okay to do right or if you're on the
Conan O'Brien show yeah
you need help here now I will preface
this by saying that my family and I are
opening up a craft brewery in Austin and
at the end of the summer this is the
very first keg wait a minute
ever kegs and was driven out from Austin
Texas
[Applause]
all right is a stupid stunt now it's
just a plug yeah here we go
the idea give me man
[Applause]
you